[Musique]
il est 8h à martinsville en estrie le
soleil est déjà haut et la journée bien
amorcée pour julie jean françois et
leurs 30 chèvres
après la traite du matin c'est l'heure
du petit déjeuner avec le monde or fold
en toile de fond
[Musique]
ici le fromage qui accompagnent les
repas de la famille et des amis
c'est la tome 5 fromages qui est au lait
cru donc son goût change au fil des
saisons
c'est sûr que en début de saison était
beaucoup plus crémeuse humide
c'est un goût qui est assez doux qu'est
ce qui vous a donné envie de faire une
tonne un art un vive ce qui nous a
inspiré beaucoup parce qu'ils sont tous
mes jean françois qui était inspiré par
le top c'est son père était français
et puis quand il revenait de france mais
il ramenait toujours une tomme de savoie
ce que c'était le fromage préféré de
votre famille je pense que dans les
années 80 au québec avait fait pas grand
fromage intéressante
c'était vraiment la fête après des
années passées à travailler sont des
fermes en savoie et dans le massif
central le décide de revenir au pays
pour faire son propre fromage
aujourd'hui ils produisent deux tonnes
de fromage de chèvre dont la fameuse
tome des broussailles un fromage bio ou
les crues
qu'ils ont
on prend les origines tout dépendant un
peu du lieu on va se trouver sur le
monde et surtout vers la france on va
voir des femmes complètement différent
johan jacques et fromager dans ses
boutiques du marché jean talon qui se
spécialise dans les produits du terroir
le mot thomas en occident donc dans la
partie sud-ouest plus de la france va
plutôt désigné un fromage frais du jour
un cahier donc on prend les ont le cai
ont le forme
on est parti sur une table si on monte
vers les alpes françaises
une tempe que beaucoup de monde
connaisse et la tomme de savoie puis la
tomme de savoie baisse est plutôt une
tomme de montagne et c'est pas un cahier
frais on va laisser affiner cet homme et
ce pendant plusieurs jours minimum de 30
jours mais pourquoi sa porte le même nom
alors si c'est si différente parce
qu'entre fromage frais puis un fromage
dans l'affinage au moins 30 jours c'est
déjà tout un monde
je pense que chacun s'est approprié le
mot tom à sa façon à sa manière dans son
langage de pays tout simplement le terme
signifie en fait un fromage à pâte semi
ferme non cuite
c'est pas mal ça
[Musique]
chaque ferme chaque lieu finalement un
ferment lactique qui est propre à ces
fourrages et propre sur les animaux dans
l'environnement
c'est ça qu'on retrouve dans le lait cru
avec les composants complexes qu'on peut
parler de l'informel de terroir parce
que ça exprime vraiment le lieu chaque
ferme a vraiment des types de faire la
différence
l'atom les broussailles son fromage de
chèvre donc ce petit goût
caractéristique de chèvre il est très
fin parce que c'est un lait qui est qui
pour chauffer donc t'échauffer juste
assez pour le faire cailler mais pas
pasteurisé avant et puis après c'est la
croûte qu'on veut aller comme qui va
donner des arômes et des gens qui
trouvent que c'est un peu comme des
champignons un peu comme deux entités à
rome de sous-bois de noisette
on le crée quelque chose si le tome qui
nous ressemble
et la musique puisqu'elle a à voir là
dedans nous habitants donc tout le monde
c'est la musique de la maison et puis
c'est aussi une façon de vie équilibré
d'affaires pagès travailler
[Musique]
depuis les années 90 il y a eu
énormément de ferme énormément de
vitrines qui sont lancés dans des
fromages fins québécois
il est ainsi convié on peut avoir est
qui qui porte ce nom
au québec on peut déjà en avoir au moins
je pense aux alentours d'une vingtaine
qu'il y en a un peu partout et ce dans
toutes les régions et l 100 elles sont
toutes complètement différente
aucune n'a une caractéristique commune
avec l'eau ce qui est vraiment très
impressionnant c'est pas mal ça mais je
proposerai commencer par l'atteinte de
grosse île est une magnifique d'hommes à
un base de lait de vache 100% très
brillant
on sent aussi qu'on est au coeur du
salon ça plaît à tout le monde c'est sûr
que ça va bien tout le monde on s'en va
sur un lait de brebis à l'écru l'atome
de kamouraska fait par le mouton blanc
un extraordinaire fromage que je vous
invite à déguster
déjà la texture la texture différente
complètement assouplir ses deux mandats
allons déguster la tomme des galets fait
par la fromagerie des grondines ici ce
qui est particulier c'est que c'est une
tome mais dans laquelle on va avoir deux
les différents stands et de chair cris
années de brebis s'étendent de voir que
ces fromages la porte le même nom qu'il
porte le même nom mais c'est pas mal la
seule chose qu'ils ont comme la wii ça
qu'ils disent
puis allons voir cette fameuse tome qui
est la tomme de savoie
l'apparenté la plus proche de tout les
tomes existantes au québec
déjà on est ici plus puissant que les
autres assurément on a vraiment cette
caractéristique noisette particulière de
cet homme est un des très grands
fromages
du continent européen mais est-ce qu'il
est homme québécois ce qui ressemble au
tome de savoie
mais alors là oui il ya quelques années
mon inventrice nat sommes des
broussailles
ici ils travaillent dans des deux
chèvres cru bio une magnifique croûte
naturelle
c'est vraiment superbe on n'est pas sur
le lait de vache mais sur le lait de
chèvres lamas je propose toujours aux
gens un morceau où il ya de la pâte et
de l'accumulateur jeu
les gens qui ont peur du fromage que ce
soit trop coûteux jordi commencer par
manger là bas
si vous avez aimé ce que vous voulez
aller plus loin et vous allez jusqu'à
manger la croûte d'accord et pour moi la
croûte
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est quand
les gens disent l'atome avec le lieu où
la fromagerie
donc quand on se dit ah bah ça c'est
comme un fromage qui est typique de tels
fromagerie c'est sûr que là avec
l'évêque ce qui se passe présentement
mais aussi de plus en plus de gens qui
s'intéressent à toutes les productions
locales puis moi mais tu es nous on rêve
pas d'avoir une ferme six fois plus gros
sous on veut garder une petite ferme et
c'est sûr que s'il y en a plein du petit
ce serait vraiment une dame ce qui après
chaque région peut avoir plein de
fromages différents puis unique
[Musique]